Este problema dice suma
5x cuadrada más 8x -3 con
2x cuadrada -7x más 13x o sea tenemos que sumar 2
polinomios y de hecho este segundo polinomio que nos dan se puede simplificar, así luego luego, por que tiene dos términos similares.
No es el término "x" cuadrada por que no hay ningún otro "x" cuadrada si no me refiero a estos 2.
A estos 2 que ambos tienen "x" elevado a la una entonces, vamos a simplificar esto.
Cuánto nos quedaría pues tenemos 13x y a eso tenemos que restarle 7x
si tenemos 13 cosas y nos quitan 7 entonces nos quedan 6 ¿Verdad? Entonces serían 6x
Entonces podemos simplificar estos 2 sumandos a 6x y el otro se quedaría igual. Déjame ponerlo como 2 x al cuadrado
más 6x ¿Muy bien? Entonces esta es la forma simplificada de este segundo polinomio que nos dan y lo que queremos es sumar
este polinomio, al primero ¿Va? Lo que vamos a hacer es escribir este, este primer polinomio aquí abajo en color morado,
y después vamos a sumar hacia abajo. Entonces vamos a escribirlo cuidadosamente para que los términos similares queden en la misma columna.
De este modo hay que poner el 5 x al cuadrado aquí, 5x al cuadrado más el 8x aquí
debajo de este 6x más 8x  y ve, el de arriba no tiene término
constante no tiene ningún término con "x" a la 0 entonces, simplemente este -3 lo voy a poner de este lado.
- 3 ¿Muy bien? Ya que tenemos los polinomios alineados podemos sumarlos, podemos sumarlos aquí de arriba para abajo.
Entonces vamos a ver qué nos queda. Déjame ponerlo con este color
rojo y entonces vamos a ver si tenemos 5x cuadrada
y le sumamos 2x cuadrada entonces, obtenemos 7x al cuadrado
5 más 2 es 7. Luego si tenemos 6x y le sumamos 8x obtenemos
14x o sea si tú tienes 6x y yo te doy 8x
obtenemos 14x, obtienes 14x en total y finalmente este -3 no hay que sumarlo con nada entonces, simplemente nos queda
-3 ¿Vale? -3 entonces ya realizamos la suma de estos dos polinomios y nos quedó
7x cuadrada más 14x -3.